welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who wanted to
buy the doctor strange supreme funko pop
but i accidentally got the wrong one
instead the wong one i said now marvel's
what if is now episode four and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the easter eggs hidden
details things you missed and also
giving our thoughts on the ending out of
the entire series this has been the
episode that's been hyped up the most i
think that is probably my favorite out
of the four though i did really enjoy
episode 2. both the showrunner and
director have said that this is the
standout that brings the entire series
together and that it's going to have big
ramifications on the mcu but does it
live up to the hype well that's what
we'll be discussing in this video and
because of this there will be heavy
spoilers if you enjoy the video then
don't be a stranger and make sure you
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this each and every week without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into what if episode 4
now episode 4 is a doctor strange
centric one that asks the question what
if stephen lost the love of his life
instead of the use of his hands it's a
brutally cruel entry that explores
themes like the five stages of grief
with strange going through things like
denial anger bargaining depression and
acceptance in his solo movie strange was
of course devastated by the loss of
movement in his hands as it meant that
he could no longer perform the surgery
that he was renowned for strange was and
still is a very egotistical character
and though we were led to believe that
these were the things that were most
important to him we very much see here
what would happen if he lost the person
that actually was variants in alternate
versions of characters were hindered at
an avengers end game but it wasn't until
loki that we got them in full force and
the multiverse breaking open has allowed
for a number of these to be created the
alternate versions we see in this
episode are very thought provoking and
it's arguably the most medius subject
matter that we've had in the show so far
now he ends up looking for the great
source for cagliostro whose name you
might remember from being attached to
the books from the ancient ones
collection strange actually took one of
these in his solo movie and inside of it
he learned a wealth of knowledge about
the dark dimension and also the time
stone in real life cagliostro was a
famous alchemist and marvel somewhat
adapted the figure for their comic
universe in the comics cagliostro was a
master of the mystic arts and he studied
the eye of agamotto through this he was
able to achieve immortality and the name
was a mauna kea that he adopted
throughout his lifetime kagliastro has
very much been an enemy to doctor
strange throughout the years and he was
also a teacher the victim on doom
kaglyastro also went under the name
obeng who is a character that we meet in
the entry he comes to strange as a guide
and though we never get this reveal it
is very similar to yoda and the empire
strikes back now we start off with the
watcher bringing out the puns as he says
even the small choices can bring out the
strangest consequences you watch as the
protagonist picks christine up in the
black lamborghini that he of course
drove in his solo film christine touches
upon his brain surgery techniques and
says that he's just performed a radical
hemispherectomy this involves separating
one part of the brain from the other and
it's very advanced and dangerous i think
that the idea of splitting something
into namely the brain which houses the
personality foreshadows what's to come
in the episode in which strangers split
in two just like the surgery this is
extremely risky and the ancient one is
unable to pull it off successfully now
though doc initially avoids the car that
caused him to crash in his solo movie it
seems like fate is determined to turn
him into a sorcerer and he's hit from
behind by a bad driver i feel like
strange very much not putting the blame
on himself for what happened like he did
in his solo movie is what makes him try
and fix things in time rather than being
in physical form thus his fixation on
the time stone becomes way more of a
driving force than what it initially was
and it becomes more of a goal rather
than just being an object that he
collects along the way now the car spins
out of control and this scene perfectly
mirrors exactly what happened in his
solo movie even down to the spins and
the eventual landing spot against the
river we attend christine's funeral and
the animators subtly bring focus to his
hands by placing them in the center of
the frame we then see him traveling to
camoutage and the clouds and beard that
he has here are identical to how they
were in his film he also performs magic
with his sling ring and whereas he
initially struggled to do this because
of his hands we see how he's far more
advanced early on this could explain why
the version in this episode is
infinitely more powerful in the mcu one
as he had his abilities down quicker
than you should have subscribed now upon
learning of the eye of agamotto we see
several shots that appeared in his solo
film including him studying the device
and also pushing the apple through
various states which of course happened
in that movie however where things
change up is that he's worn by wong and
the ancient one whereas originally it
was mordo mordo gave him a much sterner
talking to than she does and this could
be a reason why he decides to play with
time more casually in the episode we do
get a time jump of two years and it is
possible that in the mcu timeline that's
strange learned of what mordo was up to
which put him off going down a darker
path if he isn't in this reality it
wouldn't be much of a warning and
therefore it could add weight to why he
does what he does now when the ancient
one dies christine isn't there to
comfort him and though he defeats
dormammu he can't let go of the past the
anniversary of someone's death of course
brings everything flooding back and
strange sits in the sanctum sanctorum
still stricken with grief however unlike
most he's able to change things and thus
he travels back to that fateful night in
order to attempt to alter the events one
gives him a warning and i never realized
how much that guy actually does that
much like the no way home trailer
strange completely ignores it and
because of this i think we can just say
that he's arrogant and a self-assured
person that sees being told not to do
something as a challenge
yes everyone he is doctor strange he's
not mephisto now upon activating the eye
it spins open and this was actually
foreshadowed in his solo movie when he
opened up his watch draw and the
timepieces came spinning out they even
had a green light on them and i love how
this episode hammers home that it was
always strange's fate to become the
sorcerer supreme i got a lot of vibes of
the time machine at this point in the
episode and in case you haven't seen it
the first act of the movie has a very
similar plot in which a time traveler
attempts to save the woman he loves but
he realizes that no matter what her
death is a fixed point in time which
can't be changed similar to what we see
he goes through several different
scenarios but they all end the same way
and it's even more torturous for strange
because he realizes there's nothing he
can do it's really heartbreaking and
much like filling groundhog day strange
comes to the conclusion that sometimes
you just can't change things this takes
him from the stages of isolation and
anger into denial and after being
visited by the ancient one he sees her
shutting him down as a challenge rather
than being something that he should
accept because yes everyone he's just
arrogant he's not mephisto now he's
guided to a temple in the jungle and
strange slowly starts to go through it
in order to find the knowledge he seeks
in regards to changing the past now
strange is then surrounded by runes and
we saw something similar these symbols
popping up in one division what's
interesting is that there are currently
rumors that wonder will be the villain
of his sequel solo movie and i like that
that's sort of setting things up in
place with the iconography that hints
towards her showing up at some point i
will be talking about this at the end of
the video in more detail so make sure
you stick around until then but it's
quite an important thing going off what
rumors on the mcu are saying now he
falls through the floor and this idea of
reality bending around him is of course
similar to the scene in doctor strange
in which the ancient one pushes him
through it so he can experience several
realities at once you might also notice
that strange has bruises around his face
which were of course caused by the car
accident and he also wears an armani
suit which is what he had on in his solo
movie from here he meets the librarian
of the books of cagliostro aka obeng and
this idea of him guarding his work
actually pulls from the comics as they
were very much the root of his power
obeng calls him sorcerer armani to which
he corrects it to be strange and this
leads to more confusion i don't know if
it's intentional but it seems similar to
when kaiselius got confused over him
being called doctor and he ended up
calling him mr doctor which he said was
strange when stephen corrected him great
little moment and obeng leads him into
the library and we see what i believe is
idrissal aka the world tree which first
appeared in captain america the first
avenger the tesseract was placed in its
roots on a mural which red skull ended
up discovering in that movie and this
pulls from nordic legend and is very
very important
upon getting the books strange opens the
one on time manipulation to find a very
similar symbol to what we saw in his
solo movie when he studied the eye of
agamotto here he learns that one must
absorb others in order to gain the power
to manipulate time and he summons 4th
schuma gorath who we saw being pulled
through the portal at the end of episode
1. strange tries the same tactic that he
did on dol mammu and he attempts to
bargain though this doesn't work gorath
is rumored to appear in doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness but we'll
talk about that more at the end of this
video this inspires strange to begin
absorbing powers forcefully and it could
be hinting at what's happening with
mordo in the main mcu timeline he was
going to sorcerers and stripping them of
their abilities and this episode could
be hinting towards the darker path that
he's going on strange kills several
creatures and he ends up becoming dr
strange supreme which sounds like a
fancy pizza topping hey now doctor
strange supreme is a super important
character and interestingly there's some
things you might notice when he casts a
spell we've discussed through pretty
much all of our videos set in the magic
side of the mcu how certain colors
denote certain types and this is
definitely the case here for example
orange is your typical type of magic and
this is why we see the majority of the
sorcerers using it red is chaos magic
which is based heavily in reality aka
the ether and this is why it always
appears as well read now purple tends to
pull from the dark dimension and this is
why both agatha and also dormammu's
magic always manifests like this gold is
cosmic energy and this has been shown
not only in captain marvel but also the
eternals trailer now when strange
supreme casts spells though they appear
to be orange on the most part we can
also catch dark particles around him and
these give off a purple glow on his body
showing that they pull from the dark
dimension there's also a highlight of
red aka chaos magic and it hammers on
the idea that this version pulls from a
number of energies in order to cast his
spells it's some amazing attention to
detail that really adds to the episode
and also his character as a whole now
the watcher looks on but says he won't
interfere like you when you see an
argument playing out in the comments
section on facebook now i do actually
think that the watcher will interfere at
some point and that this will break
reality open which will cause carnage in
the hyundai sponsorship advert for the
show we did see him as part of the fight
and this line here just sticks out like
a sore thumb now we see as strange sucks
the life out of everyone like my
mother-in-law and he turns his attention
to a version of gora and absorbs it too
it is important to bear in mind that
this is an alternate version to the one
that we saw in what if episode 1 and
thus it isn't the one that peggy fought
and therefore the character can return
he finds obeng on his yoda death bed and
it's revealed that he's actually allowed
this to play out because he's only half
a man and therefore cannot be
all-powerful we cut back to the other
half of strange sat in the sanctuarium
but rather than ignoring wong's warnings
he takes his guidance it's revealed that
when strange travelled into the past
that the ancient one actually split him
into two and had one version remain
behind whilst the other one went to the
library this darker version has been
feasting on the universe and the only
way to stop him is for the lighter one
to take him down it brings a whole new
meaning to the phrase your own worst
enemy and outside the sanctorum strange
finds his reality being absorbed and
taken over by a black mold that
envelopes new york i've got a lot of
flashes here of spider-man web of
shadows in which the symbiotes took over
the city and though it's unconnected
it's still all connected
now he's greeted once more by the
ancient one who has sent a psychic
projection through time and it is
possible that because of this we'll be
seeing tilda swinton in the mc once more
i was always under the impression that
she couldn't see past the moment of her
death but she may have looked through
alternate timelines in order to see
potential realities that could play out
the tear in the dimension is taking
overall and though strange wants
christine back he moves under the final
stage of grief which is acceptance now i
believe that the ancient one very much
wanted strange supreme to be created so
that it could serve as a warning to the
doc that he mustn't mess with absolutes
and therefore he won't try to rescue
christine or her however her plan just
doesn't work at all and the darker
version ends up winning out which
destroys this entire dimension now here
going to the light version leads to
strange coming face to face with himself
in the void and this actually pulls from
the comics namely the happy birthday
storyline
in that dormammu attacked new york and
strange ended up casting a spell which
peter interrupted and this tore open
time in reality the pair were taken to a
black void outside of space and here
peter traveled through his lifetime to
several key points although this
darkness is typical of the void to me it
also represents the darkness that you
can slump into with depression the pair
travel back to the crash site and
strange for once acknowledges that his
arrogance can often be his downfall
because again he's not mephisto now the
pair end up facing off against each
other and i love how the moment of her
death in which he lost himself very much
becomes the moment in which they battle
for her fate however this battle extends
beyond christine and it very much
represents whether strange will accept
the truth or not now the attacks here do
mimic the ones from infinity war namely
when strange vote against thanos
including a ground attack which swirls
through the dirt strange ends up
seemingly beating his darker self but
he's attacked by a shadow further
representing how grief encompasses all
now the light version of strange comes
face to face with a vision of christine
broughton by the dark one which tempts
him with a better life however he
rejects this as there's more at stake
and you might also catch some flashes of
her face fracturing like the mirror
dimension showing that this is indeed an
illusion the dark version ends up
winning and he absorbs his better half
transforming into a monster in the
process his form incorporates the
elements of all the creatures that he
absorbed including the dragon wings and
tentacles and he brings christine back
it's very much a beauty and the beast
scenario but she realizes what stephen
has become in order to save her strange
simply cannot handle this and he calls
out to the watcher and begs that he
helps but uatu rejects this plea and
sees him as a warning of why he
shouldn't mess with time in the end he
loses christine and in the process
himself and thus the universe around him
collapses into a purple rock that exists
in the void i don't know if this is the
power stone but they look very similar
yeah but just let me know below if you
agree with that which i don't think you
will now we do know from the teasers
that strange will be coming back and
then he meets captain carter at one
point now in the trailers and
promotional material for the show we
have seen a number of characters from
across the episodes in shots together
and thus i think we can gather that
we're heading towards an avengers level
team up which will see heroes from
multiple worlds or fighting together
against one threat this was teased at in
the trailers when we saw killmonger
thanos gamora to charles lord and party
thor all standing alongside one another
ready to do battle the hyundai advert
also had the protagonists fighting side
by side against the ultron infinite who
are rumored to be the big bad in episode
9. this is obviously a multiversal
threat and i imagine that we'll see what
would have happened if ultron had a won
in a timeline and he basically took over
the entire planet if he started
spreading across the multiverse and this
will obviously open up this right on a
greater plane and i think it'll lead to
the heroes all being brought together in
order to stop him before he gets
complete control of the multiverse i
think that would be a really amazing
direction to take the series in and
instead of just having these standalone
episodes that we could build towards one
big thing for the finale i think that
it's super smart for marvel to do what
they always do and it seems like they're
applying this formula not only to what
if but also to the thunderbolts dark
avengers which val is now forming great
play by them to tease the team up and
then have all the characters come
together which i think is the only
conclusion that we can really draw at
this point every episode of what if has
ended on a cliffhanger and that just
makes the most sense to me
now that's the end of the episode and
before we talk about what we learned
this week about doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness i just want to
give my thoughts on the series so far i
think that this was a really impactful
episode with a lot of heavy themes it
shows everything that the series can be
we pretty much have a catchphrase at the
channel that things normally get good at
episode four and often when you look at
the way that shows are written the
creators tend to set up a lot of things
in the first three entries and it's
usually by episode 4 where everything
comes together i feel that's definitely
the case here and though there are still
a lot of questions i like the direction
that the show has been going the series
has shown us that as a concept it's
possible to have really fun and comedic
episodes whilst also dealing in ones
with darker more depressing themes it
shows some universes aren't necessarily
all fun and positive so yeah really
really enjoyed it and i'm looking
forward to what's in store next time now
for the next part of the video i want to
talk about what we learned this week
about doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness these are leaks so if you
want to dive out the video then i won't
be mad but as always we won't know if
these are true until we see the film for
ourselves now it has been said that
wonder is the villain of the piece and
this week daniel rbk announced that she
will be fighting a certain character
from the fox x-men universe this has
since been revealed as being professor
rex who will be played by james mcavoy
according to reports flying around the
film the multiverse of madness will be
bringing the fox universe characters
across whereas spiderman no way home
will be centered on bringing in
characters from the sony verse leaks on
the film say that after the multiverse
breaks open that wonder will attempt to
find a reality in which her children are
still alive and this will bring her into
conflict with strange as he attempts to
stop her it will also apparently feature
the illuminati a band of super secret
heroes that come together when there's a
crisis in order to stop the greater
threat according to the reports this
will be made up of professor x captain
carter bald of the brave monica rambo
and also mordo what if also potentially
sets up schumer gorath a villain that
many scoopers have said is connected to
the project and it's possible that the
movie could tie in a lot more to what if
than we initially thought take all this
with a pinch of salt as i don't know if
it's a definite and it's completely
unconnected from the people that gave me
my no way home scoops so yeah don't know
if it's true or not i've been able to
really verify anything beyond that as
kevin feige is holding a gun to my head
as we speak but it's going to be
interesting to see how this all plays
out and whether it ties into what if and
the upcoming projects that marvel have
either way that wraps up the video and
i'd absolutely love to hear your
thoughts on the episode and what you
think is going to be happening in the
series going forward we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three copies of the zack snyder dc
trilogy on the 30th of september and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we pick the comments out
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers if you
want something else to watch then you
can either check out our breakdown of
the no way home trailer or one of the
theories that we have after watching it
about 500 times i really get the feeling
that there's going to be two realities
that peter jumps between and in this
video i'll be arguing exactly why if not
and you've got something better to do
then tell you what might start off but
uh thanks for sitting until the end of
the video i've been paul you being the
best i'll see you next time take care
peace